in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape and here to talk
to us about the common cold is our
guests in the studio dr. Sabina Beck
from the department of general medicine
at the charity hospital here in Berlin
hi welcome to the show dr. Mac I'm a GP
by myself and I'm very eager to hear all
the new university research things going
on about common cold coughing and upper
air a infections and so the first thing
is there's an old saying cold takes
seven days to heal if you don't see your
doctor and if you take some medicine it
takes a week so that's roughly the same
isn't it what's true about the same well
if you ask university medicine and all
the studies all the research that has
been done into common colds and their
treatment you actually come very much to
a similar conclusion that there is not
one medication that really helps you
order to alter a common cold very much I
myself would prefer to give it a little
bit more time than just a week for the
code to resolve completely I already
also know the saying cold comes three
days stays three days and goes away
three days so that gives you a little
bit more time to completely recover but
why is it so difficult to treat the cold
actually I mean we are flying rockets to
Mars we are building nano computers why
is it so hard to treat the common cold
the common cold is not a very basic
illness because it can be caused by a
lot of different drivers so it's
actually a lot of different illnesses in
one illness and nature itself are
actually quite good at healing a code so
if you look at it you'll get a complete
recovery without any severe long lasting
complications and nearly a hundred
percent of all affected people you don't
have any side effects
you don't have any costs and so you have
to have a medication that's a lot better
than that so that's not this very hard
to find isn't good yeah right and and
what about the immune system is it is it
useful for us to boost our immune system
and just getting a cold like training
for the cold in getting it going into a
crowded bus and and catching all those
viruses I wouldn't myself exposed
voluntarily to a common cold but perhaps
it helps you to accept you have one once
you have fun that you say it's a good
for the immune system to do a little bit
of work we know that the human body is
not made to live in a sterile
environment so it has an immune system
and perhaps that wants from time to time
to do something we know for example that
children that have lots of infections or
that live on farms and have contact to
farm animals that they get less
allergies because immune system is
always working okay I mean catching
upper airway infections and the cold
it's easy to catch those if you're in
the crowd full of people but what about
going outside into the cold and being
cold does it lead to getting the cold
well like oh it doesn't cause an
infection it can if you get too cold if
you're not probably clothed you're
probably a more prone to catch an
infection because your immune system
doesn't work when you are not close you
have don't have enough clothes but you
can always catch a cold and summer on
hot days okay and the cold is something
very different to the flu the flu virus
influenza and influenza is a deadly
disease sometimes deadly disease it's
very serious disease and how can
patients differ between both the cold
and the flu well if you as a patient get
the flu you were probably noticed that
it's not a common code because you get a
very high fever you feel really sick
even if you're a young and fit person
you will lay down in bed and will not
move from there for quite an amount of
time so you will notice it's not a
common code it's a really
another infection infection that's
called caused by the influenza virus
okay thanks for that topic we talking in
against the cold but we got a lot of
viewer questions like Lube I'd I'll but
a viewer from South Africa one was told
not to do any sports while being sick
with a cold is it dangerous to do sport
well it's not certainly not advisable to
really do an exhausting sport and put
tough training when you have got a fever
and when you've got a cold but on the
other hand you wouldn't need to lie down
and bad and not to do anything it may be
good to just go for a short walk if you
feel like it have some fresh air and
that is not dangerous at all so it's
more like common sense when to stay in
bed inventory that's just like listening
to your own buddy when your body tells
your I've got a fever i want to lay down
you can do that if you feel like going
out ok Josephine andreasen from
Kazakhstan asked how long is a cold
contagious well I call this containers
for as long as you have the code and it
is even contagious before you even have
it or before you before you notice you
have it so that is probably the time
where you can't avoid exposing people to
the virus you have in your body and it
can be helpful if you're if you're a
cuff to calf in the elbow because then
you don't spread the relative iris via
your hands when you return to greet
somebody ok and even even yuck from
karate ax says he gets a painful
sinusitis sinus infection whenever he
has a cold what should he do well he
should go and see a doctor because as
certainly not a good thing to get with
every common cold you catch as sinusitis
and it's a it's not normal it can happen
from time to time as in complication but
if you get it every time there's perhaps
an analogy that's not detected yet that
might cause that you get these sinusitis
us again and again ok so with repetitive
sinusitis you need to see a doctor what
about coughing if you've got a cold and
you've got a nasty cough do you need to
see the doctor can you treat this by
yourself well a calf is are just
enormous symptom of any
common cold and it can also last a lot
longer than all the other symptoms so
perhaps the runny noses over you don't
have fever anymore but you're still
coughing for one week to week even three
weeks it's still a chest a normal cold
you don't need to be too concerned about
this you ya know you have to have a
little bit of patience and but this you
don't actually need to see your doctor
for that ok and the pharmacies are full
of a cough expectorant and cough
blockers and are they useful to go to
the pharmacy and get some tablets or can
you do this by yourself well all these
tablets are not really proven to help a
lot all these expectorants all the the
CAF blockers they are not of much use
and and they are costly so if you want
to do something you can try to drink a
little bit more to help to make the the
mucosal easier to cough up but you don't
need to spend your money on any certain
medication and if you got this tingling
sensation up your nose and up your
throat and you know oh god a cough is
starting and a common cold is starting
can you do anything to prevent it from
coming you can try perhaps to relax to
kind of a start being a bit more quiet
and to give your immune system the
chance to fight against the virus but
even in situation you wouldn't need to
buy any medication so just slowing down
and accepting that we sometimes get a
code okay thanks dr. back for being with
us in the studio thank you
you